can you explain to me what it was like
the day you finally got busted I'd met a
woman fall in love and she taught me out
of the importation and I thought I'd got
away of it I was naive to the statute of
limitations whereby the cops don't need
to catch your drugs all it takes is
someone from your past within a
seven-year period to tell them they've
done a transaction with you so ten
witness statements were given to the
police I've enrolled in college I'm
studying Spanish I'm trading the stock
market online wake up early for the
stock market open and all of a sudden
BAM a mad mad mad mad man on the door
Tempe police we've got a warrant so I
jump up look out the people it's blacked
out I'm wandering all right are these
people pretending that would be the
police found out where I live just
trying to rob me or are they really the
cops so I run to the front window peep
out and the whole building is surrounded
police marksmen police vehicles more
cops come stomping up the stairs
girlfriends at the bedroom I go through
all that all right we better let men so
we get halfway through the living room
then just door just flies off the hinges
hands above your heads get on the ground
now don't move so there was a detective
that I've called detective reading my
book party time and he just hoist me up
by the cuffs and he's like English Sean
you're a big name from the rave scene I
know this raid is gonna justify the
charges you know we've been after you
for years basically gotcha
you know so I'm still in this naive
State of Mind thing you know right yeah
raid my house is the combo for the safe
but there isn't any
in here thinking they find no drugs that
gotta release me but once we got to the
after we went through the Tempe jail
process we went over to the county jail
- sheriff joe arpaio notorious jail
system and the intake was called a
horseshoe horseshoe formation of cells
that you go for you know for days
subterranean you don't know if it's day
or night other than the heat rising and
falling against the walls during the
going through the horseshoe you get your
paperwork so you got a little counter
there's a woman behind it and she gave
me my charges and she gave me my bail
bond and that was seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars cash only on one
charge alarm which was conspiracy which
I didn't understand at a time how old
Rios I think I was about 32 33
Jesus okay yeah so in the horseshoe me
my co-defendants are all nonplussed
about what they're actually gonna charge
us for what evidence they've got you see
a judge and you plead your case and he
was having none of it with us and then
at the end of the horseshoe you get your
classification and they send you to a
cell in a county jail so most of the
co-defendants were assigned to minimum
security and in the beginning me and
Wildman were assigned to medium security
so there's quite a few ending up in
medium security but I was housed
separately from them because of the
nature of the case they didn't want me
being around my co-defendants
influencing them and stuff like that so
by the time I get to Towers jail I know
nobody in there and the Aryan
Brotherhood Skynyrd guys had just run
him wild and they come up to me right
away and they're like hey we want a word
of you getting that cell over there you
can't say no to these guys that they're
just gonna smash your head into the wall
so I go in the cell the clauses are
behind me
biggest one gets in my face
why do you charges what are you charges
charge is on a print out from the jail
it's all legal terminology like I said
I'm new to this game and I don't
understand what it means so I give the
crappiest answer in the world I don't
know my charges mean but it does not
like that one bit now the gum against
the wall like what do you mean you don't
know what your charges mean you at show
Oh you show more I don't even know what
Shawn was right so in the end it's not
National Geographic did a documentary
about my story unlocked of a broad
raving Arizona but what they didn't show
was in the end and in that scene I
pulled out my charge sheet they want to
see your paperwork they saws in for
drugs that's acceptable
nearly everyone is in drug in prison is
drug-related they saw my bail bond was
$750,000 cash only they loved that
well like damn who'd you kill you guys
the Mafia or what
and I'm like no just raves ecstasy blah
blah blah you know you shouldn't really
talk about your case when you're going
to jail
I give that out on Prison survival
advice videos now but I'd no clue on day
one and I was fearing for my life that
these guys are gonna attack me
[Laughter]
you